طبعا كلنا عارفين انك طلاب ساعات ممكن
نكون قاعدين بنذاكر ماث مثلا ونعطل في
حاجه نبقى فيه كده نقطه معينه احنا مش
فاهمينها ابدا او سواء في الكيمياء او في
الفيزياء او في اي ماده تانيه وممكن
الموضوع ياخد مننا ساعات طويله عشان بس
نفهم الحته الصغيره دي طب تخيل بقى لو انت
معك مدرس قاعد معك في البيت 24 ساعه تقول
له ايه هي المشكله بتاعتك وهو يشرحها لك
ويجيب لك مصادر لها واسئله كمان تحلها على
الموضوع ده حاجه غريبه صح تعال اوريك ازاي
هتحمل تطبيق باي جوجل لو انت في سؤال مش
عارف تجاوبه فجوجل هتجاوب لك على السؤال
وهتجيب لك فيديوهات تشرح لك الاجابه
وهتجيب لك مصادر تعلم كمان تقدر ان انت
تستخدمها عشان تتاكد ان انت فاهم الكونسبت
ده صح التطبيق بيعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وهو تطبيق ممتاز جدا ما تنساش ان انت
تشارك التطبيق ده مع اصدقائك لان اكيد حد
فيهم هي